This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. At 8.30 in the morning on the first Friday of every month, broadcast anchors around the country spring into action. It's Jobs Friday! A look ahead to the Jobs report. The monthly Jobs report is out. And here are the headlines from today's report. The lowest unemployment rate in 18 years,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。在每个月的第一个星期五早上八点半，全国各地的广播主播们都会立即行动起来。
yep, the lowest rate since the year 2000. Many companies now are so desperate for workers that they're actually giving former inmates a chance and even overlooking marijuana use to find the people they need. And if you're interested in healthcare or social services, 1.2 million job openings as of this morning.
没错，自2000年以来的最低失业率。许多公司现在对工人的需求极其迫切，以至于他们实际上在给前服刑人员一个机会，甚至忽略吸食大麻的历史来寻找他们所需的人才。
While these reports tell the story of a lush employment landscape, another set of stories describes a land, barren of opportunity. Most experts agree coal is not going to make a big comeback as per... Overall, 200,000 jobs were lost in the U.S. manufacturing industry. Still, the majority of those Americans out of the workforce aren't looking to get back in. They are sort of missing from the workplace.
虽然这些报告描绘了一幅繁荣的就业图景，但另一组报道却描述了一片缺乏机会的荒凉土地。大多数专家一致认为，正如……总的来说，美国制造业减少了20万个工作岗位。
Now we need more workers. There is a jobs gap in this country with millions of people out of work and millions of jobs that need to be filled. What explains this paradox? How can it be that there are millions of job openings that employers are desperate to fail at the same time that you have millions of people who say they're out of options? Here's Harvard economist Lawrence Katz. While the unemployment rate now is back to where it was before the Great Recession, the non-employment rate has risen as people have dropped out of the labor market.
现在我们需要更多的工人。这个国家存在就业鸿沟，数百万人失业，同时又有数百万个工作岗位需要填补。如何解释这个悖论？
Lawrence says the unemployment rate we hear about on the news, it doesn't include the people who've given up looking for work. There's a large category of individuals who don't call themselves retired, don't call themselves in school, and don't call themselves looking for work. When these discouraged people are taken into account, that record low unemployment rate 3.9% 3.9% doubles. Why aren't the people who need jobs moving to parts of the economy that are booming?
劳伦斯说，我们在新闻中听到的失业率并不包括那些已经放弃找工作的人。有一大类人，他们不称自己已退休，不称自己在上学，也不称自己在找工作。
Yeah, there are going to be lots of demand for jobs in the healthcare sector, physical therapists and home health aid. A steel worker out of a job should be willing to become a home health aid, right? Now there are many reasons why this might not happen. New professions demand new skills. They may pay less. But there's also a hidden factor that makes such transitions especially difficult. For a steel worker to become a home health aid, that's not just a career change.
是的，医疗保健领域的就业需求将会很大，比如物理治疗师和家庭护理员。一个失业的钢铁工人应该愿意成为一名家庭护理员，对吧？
It's a psychological transformation, a change in identity. So you had worked in a steel plant. You were laid off. Maybe in the past you had actually been recalled to that type of work, but in many cases that job is, you know, unfortunately permanently gone, and it's very difficult to adjust to looking forward to the types of jobs that are out there. Today we're going to look at one large group of workers affected by this identity trap and one surprising explanation for their behavior. Who are these workers?
这是一次心理转型，是一场身份的转变。所以你曾在钢铁厂工作。你被解雇了。也许过去你真的曾被召回从事那种工作，但在许多情况下，那份工作，你知道的，不幸地永远消失了。
Men. There is very little movement of men, period. This is Northwestern University's social psychologist, Alice Eglie. She and others have studied why many men are not moving to sectors of the economy that are booming. The reasons for this are complex and rooted in psychology and history. For centuries women have been locked out of different professions because of barriers built on sexism and patriarchy. Women have been forced to be flexible or in some cases to elbow their way
男人。男性的流动性非常小，完全如此。这是西北大学的社会心理学家爱丽丝·伊格利。她和其他人一直在研究为什么许多男人不愿转行到那些正在蓬勃发展的经济领域。
into professions dominated by men. But as the economy has started to boom in areas traditionally dominated by women, men have not sought jobs in those fields. If anything, they seem to actively avoid such professions. With women are attracted to the occupation, then it becomes something that women do and men would perhaps hesitate to enter. Men even avoid female dominated professions that used to be male-dominated, like working as a bank teller. There used to be quite a few males, but then there got to be so many women out of town.
但随着经济开始在传统上由女性主导的领域蓬勃发展，男性却没有在这些领域寻找工作。如果有的话，他们似乎在积极避开这些职业。当女性被某种职业吸引时，它就成了女性做的事情，而男性可能就会犹豫着不去涉足。
That man could find a bit of a masculinity threat. Oh, you're a bank teller, people would say. They see bank tellers being women, and so they think of it, oh, it's feminine, not even knowing much about what they do. This week on Hidden Brain, masculinity threats. Man up. You must be gay.
这可能会让那个男人感到男子气概受到威胁。“哦，你是个银行柜员，”人们会说。他们看到银行柜员都是女性，所以就会想，哦，这很女性化，甚至对她们的实际工作并不了解多少。
How a fear of appearing feminine shapes the lives of men, and affects us all. That many men, and affects us all. My name is Robert Vaughan. When he was 23, Robert Vaughan faced a dilemma, conformed to norms of masculinity or pursue a promising career in a field long dominated by women. His life illustrates how such norms exert a gravitational force on the choices of millions of men. Robert grew up in Belprey, Ohio. Very small town on the border of West Virginia.
本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，探讨男子气概受到的威胁。拿出男子气概来。你一定是同性恋。对 appearing 展现出女性化特质的恐惧是如何塑造男性的生活并影响我们所有人的。
There were clear expectations for the men in Belprey. Military service was a big in my community. For boys who were Robert's age, the extracurricular activity of choice was scouting. Well, one thing that really got me interested in scouting was I grew up in a... you'd call it a broken home. My parents were divorced when I was two. And I didn't really have a father figure growing up. And so scouting became a way of kind of getting bond with other men. A few years into scouting, Robert desperately wanted to go on a trip to New Mexico.
我叫罗伯特·沃恩。23岁时，罗伯特·沃恩面临着一个两难抉择：是顺从男子气概的规范，还是在一个长期由女性主导的领域追求一份大有前途的职业。
I grew up in a very poor home, you know, we were on welfare, we didn't have the money to afford such a trip and one of the men in our group actually stepped forward and paid for my way to be able to go. So it cost him a couple thousand dollars, I believe. So that was really impactful for me to have one of the men in our troop. That saw me enough as a son or at least someone he took under his wing to say, you know what, this is important. It's a good life experience. And I'm going to take the financial hit to, this is important, it's a good life experience, and I'm gonna take the financial hit
我成长在一个非常贫穷的家庭，你知道的，我们靠救济金生活，我们没有钱承担这样的旅行，我们团队中的一个人居然站出来，为我支付了去的费用。
to make this opportunity for you. Robert loved everything about the trip. You're just doing guy things. It's amazing where you're building campfires and you're putting iodine in water and you're smelling the ponderosa pine trees and you're putting iodine and water and you know you're smelling the ponderosa pine trees and you're seeing deer and bears and having to put your food in bear bags and you're just being rowdy and wrestling.
罗伯特喜欢这次旅行的一切。你只是在做男人的事情。
It's a great time. When Robby graduated from Bellybury High School in 2002, his plan was to go to college, but he couldn't afford it. I actually did not know about student loans. Surprising enough, I didn't know that you can get loans for college. I thought you just had to pay out a pocket and I was like, I don't have that kind of money. And so my opportunities were either go get some working class job in my town, working manufacturing at a plant, or join the military.
当罗比于2002年从贝利伯里高中毕业时，他的计划是上大学，但他负担不起。
He chose the latter. He enlisted in the Navy. One of the things they asked me was, where do you want to have your first duty station? I said, I want to be as far away from Ohio as possible. And they said, how does San Diego sound? I mean, it sounds good. His first job out at sea was an aviation boson's mates handler.
他选择了后者。他加入了海军。他们问我的第一件事是：“你想把你的第一个服役地点设在哪里？”我说：“我希望离俄亥俄州越远越好。”他们说：“圣迭戈听起来怎么样？”我的意思是，听起来不错。
Long job title paired with equally long walk hours. 18 hour days, we would get the aircraft from the flight deck and we would taxi them down to the hangar bay and chalk them and chain them and do that and so we'd have these long flight days of bringing aircraft down from maintenance. Robert Lightworking those long hours, living on a ship was like an extended scouting trip. Out to see, there's literally nothing else to do. You are living your life with these people 24-7. And so the downtime for us became sitting around and talking crap to each other and wrestling. So we'd be in our our break room pretty much just having full-on group rustling sessions to get out to energy and then they'd say okay we got some flights that are coming in we got to bring them down and so you're just doing that all day so it's just your
长长的职位头衔搭配着同样漫长的工作时间。每天工作18小时，我们会把飞机从飞行甲板上弄下来，然后把它们拖到机库里，垫上轮挡，用铁链锁好，日复一日地做这些事。
whole life is around doing your job. Robert joined the military because he didn't have the money for college. But after four years of service, he qualified for the GI Bill, which would cover his tuition and living expenses. In 2007, when he was 23, I got out of the military and my wife became the primary breadwinner force. He began thinking about schools and programs. His wife's father had a suggestion. My father-in-law who is a respiratory therapist said, hey, you know, you should really look into nursing.
罗伯特加入军队是因为他没有上大学的钱。但在服役四年后，他获得了《退役军人权利法案》的资格，该法案将支付他的学费和生活费。
A man encouraging his daughter's husband to become a nurse. If you've seen the movie Meet the Parents, you know this is the exact opposite of the relationship portrayed by Ben Stiller and Robert De Niro. You know Greg's in medicine too, Larry. Oh really? What feeling? Nursing. That's good.
一个男人鼓励女儿的丈夫去当护士。如果你看过电影《拜见岳父大人》，你就会知道这与本·斯蒂勒和罗伯特·德尼罗所扮演的关系完全相反。
No, really. What feeling? Nursing. No, really. What feeling? Nursing. The first thing to win through my head was well, that's a a woman's job that's a female job. That's not something that really men go into. We know how this works. Remember psychologists, Alice Eglie? With women are attracted to the occupation, that it becomes something that women do, and men would perhaps hesitate to enter.
脑海中闪过的第一件事是，好吧，那是女人的工作，那是女性的工作。这不是男人真正会从事的行业。
Why is this? What explains the reluctance of many men to enter professions that are dominated by women? Psychologist Jennifer Bas Boston used to believe there was a straightforward answer to that question. She doesn't anymore. Jennifer Boston's mother taught her at a very young age about sexism and misogyny. I was raised by a mother who was going through her own
为什么会这样？是什么解释了许多男性不愿进入由女性主导的职业的倾向？心理学家珍妮弗·博斯顿过去曾相信这个问题有一个简单的答案。她现在不这么认为了。
own feminist awakening in the 70s and 80s. So by the time I got to college, I kind of, feminism was familiar to me. I had read a lot about it. So for me, college wasn't about kind of realizing that the world is unfair toward women. Instead, college was when she began to realize how the world restricted the choices of men. Freshmanier, Jennifer lived in a co-ed dorm. She made a whole suite of new friends. Prior to college, if I was going to be just lounging around on someone's bed chatting about life and stuff and music and opinions, it was always women.
我在70年代和80年代经历了自己女权主义觉醒的母亲抚养长大。所以当我上大学时，女权主义对我来说并不陌生。我读过很多关于它的书。
And so I remember one time I had a crush on this guy and I thought he was really just the cutest thing and I asked a friend of mine a male friend, don't you think I'm gonna change his name? I'm gonna call him Dave. Don't you think Dave is really cute? Am I friend? Oh I should have changed his name. And my friend, Mark, let's call him, said, I don't know, I can't tell. And I was like, what do you mean you can't tell if David is cute? Look at him, look at his face, he's super cute.
所以有一次我记得我迷恋上了一个男生，我觉得他简直可爱极了，我问我的一个朋友，一个男性朋友，你不觉得——我要改一下他的名字，我叫他戴夫。你不觉得戴夫真的很可爱吗？
And Mark insisted that because he was a man and a straight man, he was incapable of judging the attractiveness of other men. And that enraged me at the time. I thought it was ridiculous. And I thought that he was just being kind of homophobic. Did you tell your friend, I think you're being homophobic? I don't remember if I accused him of that.
而我的一位朋友——我们叫他马克吧——说：“我不知道，我看不出来。”我说：“你怎么会看不出来戴夫可不可爱？看着他，看他的脸，他超级可爱。”马克坚信，由于他是男性，而且是异性恋，他无法判断其他男性的吸引力。
I think what I was more inclined to do was say, nobody's going to think you're gay. I really just want to know, Do you think his face is attractive? Jennifer never got an answer from her friend Mark. I assumed that he knew but just didn't feel comfortable saying. Jennifer's first reaction to this was what her mother had taught her. Guys go out of their way to appear macho because of a combination of homophobia and sexism. But over time Jennifer began to study men's behavior, she is now a psychologist at the University of South Florida, and her data prompted her to a more nuanced conclusion about why men like Mark behaved the way they do.
我以为他知道，只是觉得说出来不自在。珍妮弗对此的第一反应是她母亲教给她的道理：由于恐同和性别歧视的结合，男人们为了显得有男子气概而煞费苦心。
In one revealing experiment, her team gathered a group of about 200 men and women and sat them in front of computers. We just kind of let them write for, you know, a few minutes about a time when they violated their gender role in public. Some of the women talked about being called a tomboy. Others mentioned times when they worked in male-dominated fields and were made to feel uncomfortable by co-workers. But men? Others mention times when they walked in male-dominated fields and were made to feel uncomfortable by co-workers.
在一项极具启发性的实验中，她的团队召集了大约200名男性和女性，让他们坐在电脑前。
But men? Men say things like, I wore a pink shirt to work, or I held my girlfriend's purse while she ran into the bank, or I ordered a drink at a restaurant and when it came out to me it had a little cocktail umbrella in it and my friends teased me. So it's like, it's just mundane things like women don't say, oh I wore the wrong shirt. Why would men make such a big deal out of trivial things? The familiar explanation is misogyny, but then Jennifer began to think about the different messages that boys receive
但男人？男人会说这样的话：“我在上班时穿了一件粉红色的衬衫”、“我帮女朋友拿钱包，她跑进银行办事去了”或者“我在餐厅点了一杯饮料，端上来时上面带有一把小鸡尾酒伞，我的朋友们就拿这个取笑我”。
from a very young age. We've all heard the taunts. Are you a real man? Are they saying man up? Or they say, you know, did you leave your balls at home? Or whatever. I don't know if I'm allowed to say balls at NPR. But there's a lot of things that are off limits for men. Jennifer's research experiments gradually led her to a new understanding of why men behave the way they do. My collaborators and I argue that the male gender role itself is kind of conceptualized as a more precarious status. So, manhood is something that's hard to earn and easy to lose relative to womanhood. Manhood is something that is hard to earn and easy to lose.
我的合作者和我认为，男性性别角色本身就被概念化为一种更具不确定性的地位。因此，相对于女性气质来说，男子气概是那种很难赢得却很容易失去的东西。
This insight changed the way Jennifer thought about the behavior of her friend Mark. The pressure to not reveal any kinds of non-masculine opinions may have been so profound that it kind of made him feel like he really didn't know. Seeing this way, the driving force here is not misogyny, but fear. Men are defending something that's fragile. In terms of why this would be the case, why would you have one sex essentially have a more limited repertoire or have more policing around its boundaries? Why do women take their femininity for granted in ways that men do not take their masculinity
这种见解改变了珍妮弗对她朋友马克行为的看法。不表现出任何非男性化观点的压力可能如此之深，以至于让他觉得自己真的不知道。
for granted? That's a really hard question to answer, but I think it has to do with how men, their social status is more hierarchically organized than women's is. So men are kind of more interested in or motivated to attain social status, and that kind of then translates into what we propose is kind of a chronic anxiety about their status, and that translates into a concern about whether one's seen as a real man or not. This chronic anxiety comes through in one of Jennifer's experiments.
这种持续的焦虑体现在珍妮弗的一项实验中。
We have men do a stereotypically feminine task like braiding a mannequin's hair versus in another condition they braid three strands of thick rope. So we kind of, in both conditions, they're braiding, but in one condition it's very, what they're doing is very stereotypically feminine because there's a mannequin head and they're kind of They should got this long blonde wig on and they're asked to braid her hair And there's little pink little both that they're supposed to put in her hair When you run that test on man and you randomly assign them to either braid hair or braid rope
我们让男性做一项刻板印象中女性化的任务，比如给一个假人模特编辫子，而在另一种条件下，他们则是把三股粗绳编在一起。
What how do you test what happens next and what do the men do? So so after they do that. Oh, and also while they're doing the activity, we're video taping them. So we want it to feel very public to them, and we tell them people are going to later code your video tape. So it's not just that they're sitting alone in a room doing this. We make it feel as public as possible. So then we shut off the camera and we say, oh,
那么，在他们做完那个之后——哦，顺便说一句，当他们在做这项活动时，我们正在对他们进行录像。所以我们希望让他们觉得这是非常公开的，而且我们告诉他们，人们以后会对他们的录像进行编码。
for the next half of the experiment, we're going to have you do another activity, but this time you get to choose which one you want to do. And you can either do this brain teaser puzzle where you have to rearrange these shapes, or you can put on some boxing gloves and hit this punching pad. And so in one of our studies we found that if men braided hair, then they were much more likely to choose as their next task, the punching task. But if they braided rope, then most of them wanted to do the brain teaser. So this suggests that the ones who had done the hair braiding task felt emasculated, and so they kind of wanted to restore their masculinity by punching something, by, you know, behaving aggressively. There's something really funny about these studies, isn't there?
因此，在我们的其中一项研究中，我们发现如果男性编织了头发，那么他们更有可能选择拳击任务作为他们的下一个任务。但如果他们编织的是绳子，那么他们大多数人只想做脑筋急转弯。
Uh, sure. That's one of my favorite things about what I do is the kind of the creativity and kind of concocting these scenarios where you're measuring things that are really important but you're doing these kind of creative and interesting ways in the lab. So yeah, I like to think there's something funny about it although I also want to be taken seriously so the findings aren't funny. The methods can be funny. To be sure it's worth pointing out that societal messages that constrain men have often been developed by men.
当然，值得指出的是，那些束缚男性的社会信息往往是由男性自己制定的。
Jennifer's point is not that sexism doesn't play a role in shaping these behaviors. Her point is that men can be trapped by the gender roles that they themselves have authored. There's a way in which you can look at your work that you're doing, and say in some ways you're drawing, perhaps compassionate as the wrong word, but you're drawing a more deeper understanding of why men behave the way they do that is not just men behave the way they do because there is misogyny. Right.
珍妮弗的观点并不是说性别歧视在塑造这些行为中没有起作用。她的观点是，男性可能会被他们自己创造的性别角色所困。
I guess I feel like I have compassion for anybody who kind of finds themselves stuck in a world that makes no sense to them. So regardless of whose fault it is, I think that the struggle for status that men kind of are constantly feeling like they have to participate in, it sucks. Men worry what other men will think, what women will think, what they themselves might think. All this leads us back to Robert Vaughan's dilemma about whether to become a nurse. The precarious status of masculinity drives many men to see the profession as the equivalent
男人们担心别的男人会怎么想，女人会怎么想，他们自己会怎么想。所有这一切都把我们带回了罗伯特·沃恩关于是否要成为一名护士的两难困境。男子气概岌岌可危的地位促使许多男性将这个职业视为等同于用粉红丝带编头发。
of braiding hair with pink ribbons. Remember that clip from Meet the Parents? Not many men in your profession though though, are they, right? No, Jack. Not traditionally. This idea is deeply woven into our culture. Think about all the jokes you've heard about male nurses. So then? You've heard them on friends.
这深植于我们的文化之中。想想你听过的所有关于男护士的笑话。
Nurse found a doctor, huh? Kind of girl, isn't it? And even on shows about hospital life. Like how? Sorry, can't remember if I even on shows about hospital life, like how? Sorry, I can't remember if I mocked you yet for being a male nurse. And scrubs. She's embarrassed that she likes a nurse, and I really can't figure out why.
而且在关于医院生活的节目中也是如此。比如怎么样？抱歉，我不记得我是不是已经因为你是个男护士而嘲笑过你了。
Well, that's because you're doing a woman's job, son. Have a good move. So if you're in Robert's shoes, is there a way to silence the voice in your head that says This kind of work is a mask relating a woman's job a woman's job a woman's job London autumn 1854 Word was spreading through the city. Thousands of British soldiers had died in a conflict 1,500 miles away in Eastern Europe. The Crimean War.
伦敦，1854年秋天。消息正在城市中传播。数千名英国士兵在1500英里外东欧的一场冲突中丧生——克里米亚战争。
But these men were not killed in combat. What they were really dying of, which was of not having the wounds but infectious disease. Historian Julie Fairman at the University of Pennsylvania says Londoners were shocked to learn about the poor medical conditions in Crimea. One woman in particular felt called to action. She was wealthy from high society.
但这些军人并非阵亡于战场。他们真正死于的不是伤口，而是传染病。宾夕法尼亚大学的历史学家朱莉·费尔曼说，伦敦人震惊地得知克里米亚糟糕的医疗条件。
Her name was Florence Nightingale. She was able to convince her friends, and she had friends in high places, to let her take a contingent of nurses to the Crimea to take charge of this hospital. In November 1854, she arrived at a war camp with a group of nearly 40 nurses. She finds hospitals that are dark and they're dingy and there's no air and their soldiers lying on the ground crying out. It must have been horrendous with rodents
1854年11月，她带着近40名护士的队伍抵达了一个战地营地。她发现医院既黑暗又肮脏，没有空气，士兵们躺在地上大声哭喊。
and filth all over the place. Florence Nightingale took charge bringing cleanliness and order to the medical camps. She focused on sanitation. She made sure that injured soldiers were fed. Back home, she came to be seen as something of a trailblazer. When she returned to London, she established the world's first professional nursing school with one type of student in mind.
弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔接管了管理工作，为医疗营地带来了清洁和秩序。她专注于环境卫生。她确保受伤的士兵有饭吃。回到家乡后，她被视为某种开拓者。
She had to say every woman is a nurse, and believed that what nurses did was very akin to what women were doing in their homes. it was very akin to what women were doing in their homes. You can see Nightingale's influence everywhere in nursing, even Julie Fairman's job title. I am the Nightingale professor and honor of nursing veterans at the University of Pennsylvania School of Nursing. The Nightingale Professor. Before the Crimean War, nursing was not seen as the exclusive preserve of women. Everybody was a nurse. Everybody took care of their family members.
南丁格尔的影响力在护理领域随处可见，甚至包括朱莉·费尔曼的职称。我是宾夕法尼亚大学护理学院的南丁格尔荣休护理学教授。
They took care of the children. They took care of the wounded in battle. And so the profession, in fact, you don't even talk about profession, but the idea of providing care to people was pretty heterogeneous across men, women, and others. But Florence Nightingale was convinced that nursing was not for men. As her methods spread to Australia, Canada, and the United States, women came to dominate nursing. Men were pushed to the fringes of the field, limited to working in psychiatric
但在弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔确信护理不适合男性之后。随着她的方法传到澳大利亚、加拿大和美国，女性开始在护理领域占据主导地位。男性被推到了这个领域的边缘，仅限于在精神科病房工作。
wards. By the 1930s, men were only 2% of nurses in the United States. Even today, that number is only 10%. The idea of women being able to give that gentle caring touch when they provided care was a really strong ethos throughout the nursing profession and the public. Of course, when you think about it, there's nothing inherently feminine about nursing. Florence Nightingale literally invented that idea and made it real. So if you could turn nursing from a genderless profession to one's seen as exclusively female,
当然，仔细想想，护理并没有什么天生女性化的东西。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔字面意义上发明了这个想法并将其变成了现实。
can you make the clock turn backwards? To some degree, you can spin any job. This again, a psychologist, Jennifer Boston. You could spin nursing as a very masculine occupation. It's dangerous, it's physically grueling. You don't really have to be that warm, to be a nurse. It doesn't hurt, but you know, so our stereotype of the nurse is one that almost, you know, you could modify that stereotype and turn nursing into a profession that does seem masculine or male appropriate.
事实证明，类似珍妮弗所提出的建议的事情被摆在了罗伯特·沃恩面前。还记得罗伯特退伍后，他的岳父建议他考虑把护理作为一种职业吗？这是一个……在男性领域里薪水相当不错的职业。而且很稳定。你每星期工作三天，每次12小时。
As it turned out, something along the lines of what Jennifer proposed was presented to Robert Wann. Remember how, when Robert got out of the Navy, his father-in-law suggested he think about nursing as a profession. It's a... in the man field pays pretty well. And it's stable. You work 12 hours shifts three days a week. You can make
罗伯特没有听从岳父的建议，但他确实在一家医院找到了一份保安的工作，有一天他不得不处理两个失控的病人。
good money at it. Robba didn't take his father and lost advice but he did get a job at a hospital as a security guard and one day he had to deal with two patients who were out of control. We had a couple guys who came into the emergency room who were high presumably on PCP. I don't remember what it was at the time. And they were just very belligerent fighting. There was blood all over the place and they had to be split up into different rooms. And so we're trying to attend to them. And when you asked to secure them in one of the rooms, what was the role that you were playing?
我们有几个家伙进了急诊室，据推测他们吸食了PCP（天使尘）。我不记得当时具体是什么了。他们非常争强好胜，还在打架。到处都是血，必须把他们分开关在不同的房间里。
Yeah, security were kind of there to have eyes on and potentially hands on if we need to to help control the situation. So I was there and these guys both came out of their rooms that they were isolated into and just started fighting and they actually locked themselves in one of their rooms and destroyed the room. Did a couple thousand dollars worth of damage and blood everywhere on the ceilings and the nurses and us and the sheriffs were in the doctors are all holding them down and sedating and restraining and I was like, man, this is pretty cool.
是的，保安的存在主要是为了进行观察，如果我们需要介入来帮助控制局势，也可能会直接动手。所以我当时就在那里，这两个家伙都从他们被隔离的房间里冲出来，开始打架，他们甚至把自己锁在其中一个房间里，把房间砸了个稀巴烂。
As much as it was potentially dangerous, the action that the nurses were seeing was pretty exciting for me. You know, you think of nursing, you think of someone sitting at a bedside and being like, let me hold your hand and you see what it is realistically day to day, and for me it was 180 degrees. In fact, Robo-Joy-Lai's some aspects of nursing were actually quite similar to other things he'd done in his life. Being rowdy and restless, pretty much just having full-on group of wrestling sessions. Nurses and us in the sheriffs were, the doctors were all holding her down and sedating and just doing guy things.
罗伯特听从了岳父的建议，报名上了护理学校。现在，并不是说关于性别和护理的旧刻板印象完全消失了，但罗伯特找到了开辟自己道路的方法。
It's amazing. Robert took his father-in-law's advice and enrolled in nursing school. Now it's not as if the old stereotypes about gender and nursing disappeared altogether, but Robert found ways to carve a path of his own. His wife Christine says that when he was in nursing school, he bonded with the handful of other men in the program. Four of his closest friends are men who went through the nursing school program with him and that kind of bond that they that they build that brotherhood.
他现在在这个领域已经工作了十多年。他在心血管病房工作。
Maybe it's very kind of like military ask that they are together and so there's this common thread of like, where are the men united together, you know, in this space? He's now been in the field for more than a decade. He works in a cardiovascular unit. When you made the decision to become a nurse, did you tell your friends or family about this? I'm wondering if... Did you have hesitation about doing this? Were there an awkward conversation where you said, you know, I'm going to become a nurse and people look at you strangely? I thought I would. I thought I would get some... I thought I would. I thought I would get some at least some jeering from guys that I knew to be like, oh, you're going to be a nurse soon. We always knew that you were in the closet or there's jokes about it while if you're a nurse then therefore you must be gay.
让我惊讶的是，我并没有遇到这种情况。当我告诉我的一些朋友我打算去学护理时，他们的反应是：“这挺酷的。这是个好工作。薪水不错。你知道的，这是一份服务大众的工作。你在别人最需要的时候给予他们帮助。”
Surprisingly, I did not get that. A lot of the guys that I was friends with and when I told them you don't want to go into nursing, they were like, that's cool. It's a good job. It pays well. You know, it's a job of service. You're helping people and their time of need. And I don't think there's any better job out there as far as you literally get paid
克里斯蒂娜·沃恩发现，当她告诉别人她丈夫的工作时，人们会表现出一种思维体操。
to help people in some of their worst moments and help them get better and heal and go home. And that for me, I get paid to do that. It's awesome. And I find something really interesting if I do say my husband's a nurse, people usually want to know if there's a specialty. Christine Vaughn has seen people perform mental gymnastics when she tells them about her husband's a nurse, people usually want to know if there's a specialty. Christine Warnes seen people perform mental gymnastics when she tells them about her husband's job. And sometimes I said, oh, well, he works in cardiology, but it's like, oh, as if that's
有时我会说：“哦，他是在心脏病学部门工作，”但这就好像是说，哦，就好像这让护理工作变得更具男子气概一样。这真是一个非常有趣的动态。我知道他会跟我讲一些故事，比如他走进病房，病人会误以为他是医生。
masculine, like that's made it more masculine, nursing. And it's just a very interesting dynamic. I know he'll tell me stories just that he'll walk into a room and a patient will assume he's the doctor. And once they realize he's not, Robert says patients sometimes get uncomfortable. In fact, I just got that last week. It's just that thing of disappointment in the voice of,
一旦他们意识到他不是，罗伯特说病人有时会感到不自在。事实上，我上周刚遇到过这种情况。那种声音里的失望感，或者声音里的恐惧感，你就会想：“哦，没关系，如果你不想要男性护士完全没问题，我们可以调整。”
or the fear in their voice, and you just go, oh, it's okay, if you don't want to mail perfectly fine, we'll work with that. I can talk to the charge nurse and we'll get assignments to around. We'll make a note that you prefer female staff only. And did you do that? Did you say that? Yeah, I said that. I always say it every time. If they have an issue and sometimes they go, no, no, it's fine. It's just I've never had a nurse before that was male and sometimes they're okay with it and sometimes they do want to change and it's just not a factor.
我想花一秒钟谈谈你对这些互动的感受。我理解在职业层面上，你很乐意说：“我满足你的要求，然后继续工作。”但在某种程度上，这就是说有人基本上不想让你做他们的护士。这难道不有点伤人吗？
I just want to spend a second talking about how you feel with these interactions. I understand that at a professional level you are happy to say, you know, I'll accommodate your request and move on. But at some level this is, you know, someone is basically saying they don't want you to be their nurse. And isn't that a little hurtful? It's a little hurtful, especially when I find it somewhat hypocritical, when they'll have a doctor is a male, and they're present, they're doing the checks, and it's very intimate, but somehow as a nurse, I
有点伤人，尤其是当我发现这多少有点虚伪的时候。当他们的医生是个男性，医生在场，进行检查，而且是非常亲密的接触时，不知为何，作为一个护士，我……
mail, and that's a problem. It doesn't make any sense to me. You go, wait a minute. The doctor is a male too. Somehow you have no issue with him. That is a male nurse. You have an issue. It's contradictory. Nearly everyone agrees it's a good idea to have diversity in healthcare. But Robert says there's a double standard when it comes to men in nursing. You know, you see women going into become doctors. They are, it's, you're like, oh, it's great. It's a wonderful thing that they're going to this and we want that. But the flip side of, you got more men going in a nursing, there isn't the accolade of, oh my gosh, you are. It's great of you to be reaching out and overcoming these gender stereotypes and going into this profession. They just look at you go, I guess you probably weren't smart enough to be a doctor.
邮件，这就是个问题。这对我来说毫无道理。你会想，等等。医生也是个男性。不知何故，你对他没有任何意见。那是位男护士。你却有意见。这很矛盾。几乎所有人都认为在医疗保健领域保持多元化是个好主意。但罗伯特表示，在男性从事护理工作这方面存在双重标准。你知道的，你看到女性去当医生。她们去，那是，你会觉得，哦，这太棒了。这是一件美妙的事，她们去从事这个，我们希望如此。但另一方面，你有了更多男性去从事护理，却没有那种赞誉，比如，哦天哪，你是。你能伸出援手、克服这些性别刻板印象并进入这个行业，这太棒了。他们只是看着你，心想，我猜你大概不够聪明去当医生。
There were some things about Robert, I figured I couldn't get by just talking to him on the phone. So I went to meet him. You must be Robert. How are you? He's 5'10", he has a muscular frame and a shaved head with a goatee. I shadowed him as he exercised in his home gym.
关于罗伯特，有些事情我觉得光靠电话交流是无法了解的。所以我去见了他。你一定是罗伯特。你好吗？他身高5尺10寸，身材健硕，剃着光头，留着山羊胡。我跟着他在他的家庭健身房里锻炼。
I think for him, when he was in nursing school, starting cycling with a group of other males going through nursing school was a starting point for him of like, I'm going to have my own equipment, I'm going to do this, I'm going to take care of my body and I'm going to do so very early in the morning and religiously, wow, I was sleeping because I'm just still amazed that he wakes up before 30 in the morning to do these things. Do you tell you this? because I'm just still amazed that he wakes up at 4.30 in the morning to do these things. Do you tell you this?
我想对他来说，当他在护校时，开始和一群同样经历护校的男性一起骑车，对他来说是一个起点，就像是，我要有自己的装备，我要做这件事，我要照顾好自己的身体，我要在清晨很早的时候非常虔诚地去做，天哪，当时我还在睡觉，因为我还是惊叹于他每天早上4点半醒来做这些事。你告诉过你这个吗？因为我还是惊叹于他每天早上4.30醒来做这些事。你告诉过你这个吗？
Today, he thankfully moved the session to 4.30 p.m. Robert has set up a bunch of equipment in his garage. There's a bench, stacks of weights, dumbbells, a pull-up bar. My favorite things are the motivational messages plastered on the wall. One sticker says, Discipline equals freedom. Robert says it's from Jocco Willink. Jocco Willink, he's Navy SEAL, he's on Twitter, he's quite popular, but he has a method. It's a squat day, you have a push day, you have a lift day, and you have a pull day. As I listened to Robert, I couldn't help but remember the study that Jennifer Boston had conducted.
今天，他谢天谢地把训练时间改到了下午4点半。罗伯特在车库里摆放了一堆器械。有一个长凳、一叠叠杠铃片、哑铃、一个引体向上杆。我最喜欢的是贴在墙上的励志标语。其中一个贴纸上写着：纪律即自由。罗伯特说这是乔科·维林克（Jocco Willink）说的。乔科·维林克，他是海豹突击队员，他在推特上很活跃，相当受欢迎，但他有自己的一套方法。今天是深蹲日，你有推举日，你有举重日，还有拉力日。听着罗伯特的话，我不禁想起詹妮弗·波士顿（Jennifer Boston）做过的那项研究。
When men are asked to braid hair, they compensate by punching bags to reclaim their lost masculinity. Could some of Robert's intense exercise regimen be connected to his job as a nurse? Could the sports truck he drives to work every day, be a defense mechanism. I think a lot of guys who might go into healthcare are interested in health and fitness. They're interested in being healthy, being fit, being active, and so they're doing a lot of they're running marathons, they're doing weightlifting competitions,
当被要求给头发编辫子时，男性会通过击打沙袋来弥补，以重拾他们失去的男性气概。罗伯特的一些高强度锻炼计划是否与他作为护士的工作有关？他每天开着去上班的那辆运动卡车，会不会是一种防御机制。我认为很多从事医疗保健的男性可能对健康和健身感兴趣。他们对保持健康、强壮、活跃感兴趣，所以他们做了很多，他们跑马拉松，他们参加举重比赛，
they're doing bodybuilding competitions. And I think part of it may also be showing, hey, you know, I'm not this, I'm not sure the wording I'd wanna use for it. I'm not a the wording I'd want to use for it. I'm not a a guy who is this meek or I don't know. I'm not a feminine or I'm not this nurse stereotype. Maybe it's pushing against the stereotype of what you might assume a male nurse would be.
他们参加健美比赛。我想部分原因可能也是为了展示，嘿，你知道，我不是这种，我不知道我该用什么词来表达。我不是一个我想要使用的词。我不是一个性格温顺的人，或者我不知道。我不是女性化的，或者我不是这种男护士的刻板印象。也许这是在对抗你可能对男护士产生的刻板印象。
And so it's saying, you know what, I'm not that. I'm actually pretty manly in other aspects. Wait, that's, that looks like something you got back from the hospital. It looks like a nursing thing. It is. We use these on our patients. And so I'll keep a track of my heart rate and real time, so 171.
所以在说，你知道吗，我不是那样的人。实际上我在其他方面挺有男子气概的。等等，那个，看起来像你从医院拿回来的东西。它看起来像个护理用品。是的。我们在患者身上使用这些。所以我会实时追踪我的心率，171。
While Robert rejects the idea that his own fitness regime is a form of psychological compensation, he does see himself compensating in another area. I've had patients where I've had them a couple days, two, three days. And at first, they were hesitant about having a male as a nurse, and they would pull me aside as they're discharging home and they say, you know what, you were the best nurse
虽然罗伯特否认他自己的健身计划是一种心理补偿形式，但他确实看到自己在另一个领域进行补偿。我曾照顾过一些患者，照顾了两三天。起初，他们对由男性做护士有些迟疑，但当他们出院回家时，他们会把我拉到一边说，你知道吗，你是我在这里期间最好的护士
the entire time I was here. I had a lot of female nurses and they were great, but you were actually more gentle and more caring because you are acutely aware of the fact that you're being judged in that manner. Robert was drawn to nursing because he saw the job as an extension of the identity he'd established in the military. When in his decade as a nurse, he's grown to admire the skills he once considered feminine. My thinking on this is evolved to the point where I can say men are still just as compassionate and empathetic.
我遇到过很多女护士，她们都很好，但你实际上更温柔、更有爱心，因为你敏锐地意识到自己正在以这种方式受到评判。罗伯特被护理工作吸引，是因为他将这份工作视为他在军队中确立的身份的延伸。在当了十年护士期间，他逐渐钦佩那些他曾经认为是女性化的技能。我对这一点的思考已经演变到这样一种程度，即我可以说明男性同样富有同情心和同理心。
We just express that sometimes in a different way. You know, being a father, I have two kids. You know, I don't love my kids any less than my wife does, but I show my love and my compassion, my empathy to my kids sometimes in a different way than my wife does. Is that your trampoline? My daughter, who's four, almost four, goes up to my mother and says, Grandma, look at my muscles. I work out. Oh my gosh, what are these?
我们只是有时用不同的方式表达这一点。你知道的，作为一个父亲，我有两个孩子。你知道的，我爱我的孩子并不比我妻子少，但我向我的孩子表达我的爱、我的同情和我的同理心的方式，有时与我妻子不同。那是你的蹦床吗？我女儿四岁了，快四岁了，她走到我母亲面前说，奶奶，看我的肌肉。我锻炼。哦天哪，这些是什么？
Are these two-pound dumbbells? My daughter wakes up and she wants to do push-ups with me in the morning and she wants to eat my protein bar when I'm waking up in the morning. You know, the impact that I have on her, you know, is me being a role model for making her a strong, independent woman. When policymakers talk about interventions to help the jobless find work, they talk about vocational schools and retraining skills. They don't talk about how, without anyone saying it aloud, one half of the population might be systematically excluding itself from the very parts of the economy that are booming. Robert was reluctant to pursue nursing because of all the narratives about male nurses. Kind of girl, isn't it?
这是两磅重的哑铃吗？我女儿醒来后想在早上和我一起做俯卧撑，当我早上醒来时她想吃我的蛋白棒。你知道的，我对她产生的影响，你知道的，就是我成为一个榜样，让她成为一个坚强、独立的女性。当政策制定者谈论帮助失业者寻找工作的干预措施时，他们会谈论职业学校和技能再培训。他们没有谈论的是，在没有人公开说出来的情况下，一半的人口可能正在系统性地将自己排除在经济中正在蓬勃发展的那些领域之外。由于关于男护士的种种说法，罗伯特一度不愿意从事护理工作。有点像个女孩，不是吗？
Of course, there is another word for these emasculating jokes. They are stereotypes. When it comes to fighting stereotypes, we often imagine that the right approach is to explain why the stereotypes are wrong. But Robert's life suggests a different solution and perhaps a more effective one. Stereotypes are powerful because the stories we tell about ourselves are powerful. They shape how we see the world and how the world sees us. But in the end, they are only stories. And stories? We can rewrite them. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell and Kimila Vargas Drestrepo.
当然，这些 emasculating（削弱男性气概的）笑话还有另一个词。它们是刻板印象。在对抗刻板印象时，我们经常想象正确的方法是解释为什么刻板印象是错误的。但罗伯特的生活暗示了一种不同的解决方案，或许也是一种更有效的解决方案。刻板印象之所以强大，是因为我们对自己讲述的故事很强大。它们塑造了我们如何看待世界，以及世界如何看待我们。但归根结底，它们只是故事。而故事？我们可以重写它们。《Hidden Brain》的这一期由帕斯·沙（Path Shah）制作，由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）剪辑。我们的团队包括詹妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、刘托马斯（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）和金米拉·巴尔加斯·德雷斯特雷波（Kimila Vargas Drestrepo）。
We had audio assistance from Andy Huthar. Our unsung hero today is Marilyn G. Wax. In her former role as NPR Senior Business News Editor, Marilyn took me a side one day and told me that hidden brain needed to examine how identity could shape the unemployment rate. Today's story is a direct result of her suggestion. If you like the story, you have Marilyn to thank. We know that we do. One last thing before we go, we're just getting started on a show about living vicariously,
我们的音频助理是安迪·胡塔尔（Andy Huthar）。我们今天的无名英雄是玛丽莲·G·华克斯（Marilyn G. Wax）。在她担任NPR高级商业新闻编辑的前职中，玛丽莲有一天把我拉到一边，告诉我Hidden Brain需要探讨身份如何影响失业率。今天的故事正是她建议的直接结果。如果你喜欢这个故事，你得感谢玛丽莲。我们知道我们会的。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们刚刚开始筹备一个关于间接体验的节目，
watching other people perform athletic or creative feats instead of attempting those things ourselves. Do you prefer cooking shows to cooking? Has watching exercise videos come to take the place of working out yourself? Ever feel that pornography is better than intimacy with an actual partner? If you're willing to share your personal story with us, record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at HiddenBrain at npr.org. Use the subject line watching others and give us a phone number where we can reach you.
观看其他人表演运动或创意绝技，而不是自己去尝试这些事情。你比起做饭更喜欢看烹饪节目吗？观看健身视频已经取代了你自己的锻炼吗？有没有觉得色情内容比与真实伴侣的亲密关系更好？如果你愿意与我们分享你的个人故事，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送至 HiddenBrain@npr.org。主题行请使用 watching others，并给我们一个可以联系到你的电话号码。
the subject line watching others and give us a phone number where we can reach you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
主题行请使用 watching others，并给我们一个可以联系到你的电话号码。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。